We'll close block grounding for a grounded pattern chair, even a grounded sheet.
Yes and no, so it depends on how much clothing you have, and depends on what kind of clothing it is, the more synthetic, the clothing, the more it will block the grounding.
So it's obviously better to have a skin to a grounded pad contact, and I will tell you we have some people that use the grounding sheet as a over the top.
I said, you know, and it's what it's recommended is to put it underneath the fitted sheet. I have some people put it on top of the fitted sheet so they're laying on top of it.
I have had some people over time put the grounded sheet over them in different areas, using it during the day to protect them, and they have to sit at a, at a computer and they feel like they're in an area they live in the cities or something where they're getting a lot of.
EMFs, I've had people that would get an EMF meter and just read where their office is is really super high at EMFs and they'll put the grounding sheet over the top of them.
So there's all sorts of different ways to use it.
The point is though, really, Weber, what is the purpose of grounding you are picking up positive ions from EMFs from electrical dirty electricity in your house from everything in the world, you're picking up these positively charged ions.
The idea of grounding is that you want to disperse them with a balanced negatively charged ions and you get the best source of negatively charged ions is the earth itself, you go out in the yard.
You don't need a grounding pad to sit out all day if you walk it out in the yard every day and you're going for a short walk and touching the ground and dispersing those if you have a dog that you let outside it is running around outside in the yard and then you come in and you hug the dog, you're basically dispersing all those electrons.
If you think of it as an electrical charge and that you're trying to disperse that electrical charge, that's probably the best way to get it into your head that way.
It's not a matter of you need to stay grounded 24-7 hours a day or you're going to have these horrible negative effects.
It's the accumulation of these that isn't dispersed.
So if you can think of it that way that will be better.
Thank you Ed for that clarification on that. We should do that.